hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
about Midway through his treaties on
controlling anger Cicero is going to
advise us to try to cultivate a
particular emotional comportment or
disposition it's one that in Greek is
ukolia and it can be translated as it
typically is is cheerfulness but also as
contentment also by this word that we
don't use all that often affability this
sense of being cool we could say with
other people not cool as in like I'm too
cool for you or anything like that but
being being decent being nice being uh
you know engaging with them but not you
know overly so just being willing to
smile to chat to be of good cheer with
them and he tells us in the first
instance that we should receive gave or
accept Deco my our friends with
cheerfulness ukolia and then he talks
about two other things as well in their
uh laughter Galos and so you know we
should be willing to joke around and
have fun and what we could translate as
friendliness or a friendly disposition
filofrosune so filos is the you know the
word that we get friendship from fidane
means to feel affection like that of
friendship and the frosune you know it's
sort of bringing up the mindset we could
say or sort of friendly mindset towards
them and here he's talking about three
things that kind of go together and he
will also talk about laughter and joking
around a little bit later telling us
that you know we need to be a little bit
careful in this so that he says we
should allow no place to anger even in
jest even in joking around with other
people because that brings enmity or
hatred in where friendliness was so you
know we want to try to be friendly or
cheerful with the people that we are
indeed viewing as friends whether
they're very close friends or you know
what we could call work friends or
friends in social media and then a
little bit after that in the discussion
of food he's going to bring up
cheerfulness again and he's going to say
that we must accustom ourselves to make
cheerful use of any kind of table
utensils and not to prefer this service
to that as some men do who select one
goblet or horn out of the many they have
and will drink from no other right and
so we shouldn't be overly particular if
we have to eat out of paper plates and
with red Solo cups that's that's fine we
can be we can have a good meal and we
can be cheerful even in cases like that
and if we're being served things on very
fine china with Crystal that's nice too
but we don't have to be
too worried or concerned to have just
the right sorts of things you know we
could have mismatched silverware that's
fine if you're cheerful and I think we
could generalize this away from the
table to all sorts of other things you
know your laptop is not working
perfectly the way that it was when you
first purchased it well you know you
probably need to do a tune-up but until
then you don't need to get angry about
it you know your clothing as well maybe
you grew a little bit too large for it
and it's confining you can still be
cheerful in using it your tie is perhaps
gone out of fashion well you know that's
not that big of a deal one can have
eucalia or cheerfulness with regard to
any of the things that one is working
with and you should probably expect
things to not go entirely your way so
you can in fact be cheerful
a little bit later he says something
really quite interesting he's saying if
we can do this with some things then we
can do this with people of some sort and
if we can do it with those people we can
also do it with these other people so
he's drawing some inferences almost like
setting us up in a scale with with
gradations he talks about a cheerful
attitude in Korea again towards things
so this is a very wide range of stuff it
could be physical objects like you know
does the book open to the right page
does the book have what I want in it the
Blackboard does it cooperate with me or
does it squeak when I run the truck over
it right so those are physical things we
could also extend it to Affairs to
things that we're doing or involved in
or that are affecting us we can be angry
or we can be cheerful with respect to
those now he says that if we can do that
in relation to things then we can do
that in relation to or Pros oikitas that
is in in those who were in the household
with and those who are subject to us the
household servants and again here we
might think of Technology because not
too many of us actually have household
servants but when I get the vacuum out
to start vacuuming around do I get angry
at the vacuum for not doing what it is
that I wanted to do or do I cheerfully
you know Whistle While I Work you could
say right and if you know I get to the
end of the chord I can say oh well I
need to unplug it and plug it back in
over here that's this attitude is up to
me but you know if we do have servants
or people other people in our household
then you know if we can be cheerful
towards things why can't we be cheerful
towards them as well and then he goes on
and says
if to servants or slaves a person who's
cheerful will evidently be so to his
friends a very important preoccupation
here for for Plutarch and how we deal
with the people that we claim to be
friends with he says
also with respect to friends and then
most importantly to those who are
subject to our rule so to speak Pros
it would be the people who are being
ruled over ruled over by who by us the
people who should be cheerful with them
so if we have employees if we have
contractors if we have suppliers if we
have delivery people if we're at a
restaurant and we have a server or you
know the uh cook we want them to do
things exactly our way we can instead be
cheerful about stuff if a state comes
out and it's not perfectly medium well
maybe that's not that big of a deal it
doesn't necessarily have to go back to
the the cook and tick them off as having
been a grill cook before I can tell you
that most Grill Cooks don't really like
that so we can we can go on from there
so there's this interesting
three-part progression things servants
then friends and those one rules
the the last thing that he brings up in
terms of cheerfulness is a kind of
listing and exhortation on his part he
says a cheerful disposition eocolia in
some circumstances is helpful or
literally comes to our Aid boethi which
means uh to come to one's Aid like in
Warfare right so it comes to our Aid in
dealing with anger it adorns uh epicos
May so this is coming from the word
Cosmos which means something like order
Beauty right so it doesn't just Adorn
but it adorns well or beautifully or in
an orderly manner right and then uh it
makes Pleasant
right and this is coming from Hades
pleasure right the or the pleasant so it
it makes the person who has this
cheerfulness Pleasant to others which
means that uh it's it's not only good
for removing their own anger or
substituting for their anger it's also
going to hopefully conduce to other
people being less angry in the
situations that they're in and he
follows this up by saying by its
gentleness
in this case
um this is priorities the disposition of
calmness mildness good temper gentleness
we can translate it in a lot of ways he
says that it overcomes anger thumos and
morosen as Deuce coleus now it should
overcome Deuce coleus because it is
right so your the the kolia part uh can
either be oh good or it can be Deuce bad
right or uncomfortable or however you
want to translate it so by cultivating
an attitude of cheerfulness of not
taking things overly seriously of trying
to look on the better or good side of
matters and Affairs you can really do a
lot to cut off anger not only in
yourself but in other people and he
gives a few interesting examples that
we'll close with so he says euclides
when his brother said to him after a
quarrel damned if I don't get even with
you right so there's the Revenge aspect
of anger euclides answered as for me may
I be damned if I don't convince you
right so he's not responding to anger
with anger pull him on when a man who is
fond of precious stones and quite mad
about expensive seal Rings reviled him
so he's saying bad stuff to him made no
answer but he fixed his Gaze on one of
the Rings and Ida closely the man
accordingly was pleased so he changes
his disposition and said to him don't
look at it in this life poem on but
under the sun's Rays then it will appear
to you far more beautiful
aristipus when anger had Arisen between
him and eskinas these are two Socratic
students right and someone said where
now aristipus is the Friendship of you
two replied it is asleep but I shall
awaken it and going to escanese he said
do I appear to you so utterly
unfortunate and incurable as not to
receive correction from you and escanese
says no wonder if you who are naturally
Superior to me and all things should in
this matter also have discerned before I
did the right thing to do so he's he's
talking about cases where
people have deliberately adopted a
response different than anger a response
that treats the other as you know
somebody who's an object of friendship
or of a benign disposition and so
cheerfulness can really do quite a lot
according to Plutarch in helping us to
reign in and control our emotion of
anger